PREVIOUSLY ON
"AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL"...
AFTER THE DEATH OF A FRIEND
FROM HOME...
DAMN IT!
KAHLEN HAD
TO FACE HER GRIEF
AT A GRAVEYARD PHOTO SHOOT.
DO YOU GUYS KNOW
WHAT'S WRONG WITH KAHLEN?
SHE HAD A FRIEND
THAT JUST DIED.
OH, MY GOSH.
BUT SHE CHANNELED HER EMOTIONS
INTO A FIERCE PERFORMANCE.
(screaming)
GOT IT, GOOD.
CHRISTINA STRUGGLED
TO HEAT UP A LUSTY SHOT,
BUT IN THE END IT WAS TATIANA
WHO DIDN'T DELIVER.
THIS WEEK
I THINK SHE JUST FELL APART.
AND SHE WAS SENT HOME.
ONLY SIX GIRLS REMAIN.
WHO WILL BE ELIMINATED TONIGHT?
♪♪♪
IT GETS MORE
AND MORE NERVE-RACKING
EVERY SINGLE ELIMINATION.
MM-HMM.
WHEN THEY SAID TO PICK
ONE OF 'EM
WHO WANTS THIS
MORE THAN THE OTHER...
I THOUGHT IT WAS MICHELLE.
YOU THOUGHT SHE WAS GOING?
NO, I THOUGHT MICHELLE WAS
GONNA BE THE ONE TO STAY.
MICHELLE DOES WANT IT
MORE THAN TATIANA.
CRAZINESS, BRITTANY.
BEING IN THE FINAL TWO,
I WAS LIKE, "OH, MY GOD!"
I KNOW.
BUT I REALLY, REALLY
DID THINK I WAS GOING HOME.
BECAUSE I WAS ONE
OF THE LAST TWO
STANDING UP THERE
TO GET MY PICTURE,
I HAVE TO STEP MY COMPETITION
UP IN EVERY ASPECT,
NOT ONLY
IN THE PHOTO SHOOTS
BUT IN EVERY SINGLE CHALLENGE
THEY GIVE US, TOO.
I'VE CHANGED SO MUCH.
NO, I TOLD SOMEBODY THAT
THE OTHER DAY.
LIKE, LOOKING AT
THIS PICTURE,
I DON'T LOOK AT THAT
AND SEE YOU ANYMORE.
OH, LOOK AT THIS GOOBER.
TYRA MAIL! AAH!
WHO WANTS TO READ IT?
YOU GOT IT?
YEAH!
"ARE YOU BORN TO BE WILD?
BE READY AT 8:30 A.M."
WHAT THE HELL IS
THAT SUPPOSED TO MEAN?
"TO BE WILD."
IT'S ANIMALS.
MUSIC VIDEO!
THERE ARE SIX GIRLS LEFT
IN THE COMPETITION,
AND WE ALL
GOT TO STEP IT UP.
I LOVE YOU, GIRLS!
I DON'T CARE HOW MUCH
THE OTHER GIRLS
SAY THEY WANT IT,
I WANT IT
MORE THAN ALL OF 'EM.
BORN TO BE NAKED, YEAH!
YOU KNOW BRITTANY WAS BORN
TO BE WILD.
THIS IS HOW I DANCE
WHEN I GO OUT.
♪♪♪
LET'S GO, KIDS.
WE'RE LEAVING.
LIKE 16.
CARBS ARE MY ENEMY
AND MY FRIEND.
LIKE, I LOVE BREAD,
BUT I GOTTA WATCH
HOW MUCH I EAT,
BECAUSE I'M A MODEL.
I REALLY HAVE TO
FOCUS ON THIS.
KEENYAH, SHE HAS GAINED
ABOUT 10 POUNDS.
THE GIRL CAN SNACK
LIKE NO OTHER.
♪♪♪
(screams)
LOOK WHO IT IS!
IT'S RAINING,
AND THERE IS J. ALEXANDER
WAITING FOR US
WITH AN UMBRELLA.
GOOD MORNING,
AND CONGRATULATIONS
TO THE FINAL
SIX LUCKY BITCHES.
(laughs)
TODAY WE HAVE
SOME ANIMALS, ACTUALLY.
YOU'RE GONNA BE STUDYING
THE ANIMAL
AND LEARNING
FROM THE ANIMAL HOW TO POSE,
AND THIS IS ACTUALLY GONNA BE
PART OF YOUR CHALLENGE,
POSING LIKE THE ANIMALS
THAT YOU'VE SEEN.
WE HAVE LIONS AND TIGERS
AND BEARS.
OH, MY!
I HAVE ERIC AND JET.
HI.
AND THEY WILL EXPLAIN
THE SAFETY OF THESE ANIMALS.
I'M A LITTLE NERVOUS 'CAUSE
THESE ARE WILD ANIMALS.
IF AN ANIMAL COMES AT ME,
THANK GOD I CAN RUN,
AND I AM FAST,
BECAUSE THAT'S WHAT
I'M GONNA DO.
IF THE ANIMAL GETS AWAY
FROM US, DO NOT MOVE.
THIS ANIMAL
WILL RUN AFTER YOU.
ALL RIGHT.
GREAT,
THERE GOES MY GAME PLAN.
HERE WE HAVE ATHARI,
THE WONDERFUL LEOPARD.
LOOK AT THE PAWS.
YOU SEE THE ANGLES
OF THE BODY?
LOOK AT THE EXTENSION.
WHEN I TELL YOU YOU GIRLS,
"STRETCH FROM THE WAIST UP,
BABY," THERE YOU HAVE IT.
(snarls)
AAH!
OOH.
AND GIRLS, THIS IS KISMET.
KIZZY IS HOLDING HER POSES
FOR 30 SECONDS OR MORE.
SOMETIMES YOU HAVE TO DO THAT
IN A PHOTO SHOOT.
(roaring)
KIZ, KIZ!
KIZZY!
(roars)
GET BACK ON YOUR SEAT.
NOTICE, I DID NOT FLINCH
AN INCH.
I WAS BOUND FOR THE TOILET,
BUT I DIDN'T FLINCH.
(giggles)
OH, MY.
(roars)
KIND OF LOOKS LIKE
MY LAST BOYFRIEND.
THIS IS BAMBAM.
THAT IS A LOT OF DROOL.
(roars)
STUDY WHAT BAMBAM'S DOING.
PAY ATTENTION
TO THE MOVEMENT.
SEE, LOOK,
CATCH, CATCH, CATCH.
EXTENSION.
I'M REALLY TRYING
TO STUDY THE BEAR
AND SEE
HOW I CAN IMITATE A BEAR.
IT'S REALLY HARD
TO IMITATE A BEAR.
(roars)
I DON'T CARE
FOR THE BEAR SO MUCH.
IT'S GOT A LOT OF SLOBBER,
AND I JUST KIND OF KEEP
STARING AT THE SLOBBER,
AND IT'S REALLY
GROSSING ME OUT.
GIRLS, I DON'T WANT
ANY OF THAT WHITE STUFF
COMING OUT OF YOUR MOUTH
AS YOU POSE.
EW!
WHO WANTS TO COME UP
AND GIVE HIM A KISS?
(roars)
WANT HIM TO GIVE A KISS?
ALL RIGHT.
COME HERE, BABY.
OOH, LOVIN' IT!
EW!
EXCELLENT.
HE LIKED THAT.
YOU ENJOYED IT, TOO.
EXCELLENT.
(giggles)
YOU CAN PUT ME IN THE WIND
AND IN A GRAVE
AND ALL
THIS OTHER KIND OF STUFF,
BUT KISSING THAT SLOBBER,
I'M SORRY, EW!
THE BAR HAS BEEN RAISED.
COME ON, KAHLEN,
YOU CAN DO IT.
KAHLEN, GET RIGHT IN THERE.
FURTHER,
CLOSER, CLOSER, CLOSER.
LET HIM TAKE IT.
THERE YOU GO!
THAT'S JUST SICK.
I WANT TO GO HOME
AND BRUSH MY TEETH
FOR THE NEXT,
LIKE, FIVE DAYS.
(roars)
EW.
OKAY, GIRLS, GIVE ME A POSE
THAT YOU REMEMBERED FROM
ATHARI THE LEOPARD.
WHY IS EVERYONE
GETTING DOWN ON THE GROUND?
MOST OF THE ANIMALS
THAT WE'VE SEEN TODAY
ARE 4-LEGGED ANIMALS,
SO OF COURSE OUR POSES
ARE GONNA BE, LIKE,
ON ALL FOUR,
BEING AN ANIMAL,
BEING A WILD CAT
IN THE RAIN ON THE GRAVEL.
IT SUCKS.
(laughs)
KISMET, THE TIGER
WHO ALMOST TOOK A LITTLE
SWIPE AT ME, I THINK.
MAYBE IT WAS MY SCENT,
ALL EAU DE NEGRESSE.
♪♪♪
I LOVE IT THAT CHRISTINA
LOOKS LIKE A LAWN JOCKEY.
I ABSOLUTELY LOVE IT.
I WANT TO PUT A LANTERN
IN HER HAND.
FORTUNATELY, I DON'T HAVE
ANY MARSHMALLOWS TO FEED YOU.
GET INTO THE WHOLE BAMBAM
MOVEMENT RIGHT NOW.
♪♪♪
I THINK I DID PRETTY GOOD,
AND I TRIED NOT TO BE
SO LITERAL.
BRITTANY, SHE TOOK
EVERYTHING LITERAL,
SO HER MOUTH WAS ALWAYS
LIKE, "RAWR!"
OK, GIRLS, UP, UP.
THANK YOU. RELAX.
THE GIRL WHO I THINK DESERVED
TO WIN THIS COMPETITION,
BECAUSE SHE DID A LOT MORE
WITH HER FACE, WAS BRITTANY.
(snarls)
(laughs)
IF I END UP GOING HOME,
AT LEAST I'VE WON A CHALLENGE.
IT'S NOT LIKE,
"SHE'S JUST A LOSER.
SHE DIDN'T WIN ANYTHING."
YAY!
SO YOU GET
TO PICK TWO FRIENDS.
I PICK KEENYAH AND CHRISTINA.
I HAVE NO IDEA
WHAT THE REWARD IS YET.
I JUST KNOW I GET TO
BRING ALONG TWO FRIENDS.
ACTUALLY, THERE'S IS
ONE MORE ANIMAL
THAT I HAVE TO SHOW YOU
THAT'S THE FIERCEST ANIMAL
OF ALL.
HELLO!
HOW ARE YOU?
HI!
ARE YOU GUYS THE RAIN GIRLS?
YES.
WEATHER GIRLS TODAY.
LOOK AT MISS J.
THE PARK RANGER.
THE REASON WHY I WANTED
YOU GUYS TO COME HERE TODAY
IS BECAUSE FOR MY VERY FIRST
FASHION SHOW IN LOS ANGELES,
THE DESIGNERS
ARE LIKE...
(foreign accent)
"TYRA, I WANT YOU TO GET
ON THE STAGE,
AND I WANT YOU
TO LOOK LIKE A CAT."
(normal voice)
SO I GET ON THE RUNWAY
AND I'M, LIKE, WALKING,
AND I GET TO THE END
AND I AM LIKE, "MEOW."
(hisses)
AND I WENT BACKSTAGE,
AND THE DESIGNER WAS LIKE...
(foreign accent)
"YOU HAVE RUINED MY SHOW.
WHAT WAS THAT MOVE?
I DON'T KNOW WHAT YOU DID."
(normal voice)
SO I REALIZED THAT HE MEANT
TO BE FELINE-LIKE.
WHEN YOU DO MODELING JOBS,
A PHOTOGRAPHER WILL TELL YOU,
"I WANT YOU TO BE LIKE A BIRD,
I WANT YOU TO BE LIKE A CAT.
I WANT YOU TO BE LIKE
A RHINOCEROS."
YOU CAN LEARN HOW
TO DO IT EXACTLY
AND THEN KIND OF MOLD IT
INTO YOUR OWN THING.
YOU GUYS ARE DOING
A SPECIAL PHOTO SHOOT TODAY.
IT'S AN AMAZING SHOOT
BECAUSE YOU GUYS NEED MODELS
WITH YOU!
WHOO!
THESE ARE YOUR MODELS TODAY.
OH, WOW.
ARE YOU READY?
THEY'RE NO JOKE.
YOU SEE, THEY'RE TRYING
TO GET AT YOU RIGHT NOW.
WHAT?
YEAH. THIS IS--I DON'T KNOW.
YOU THINK THEY CAN DO
THE SHOOT TODAY?
I MEAN, WE MANAGED--
WE DID IT ALL MORNING LONG.
I DON'T KNOW.
I'M COLD,
AND I'M NOT FEELIN' THE RAIN,
I'M NOT FEELING
THIS WEATHER.
AND... I THINK Y'ALL
ARE GONNA HAVE DO
THIS SHOOT IN AFRICA!
(screaming)
OH, MY GOD!
YOU GUYS, WE'RE GOING
TO SOUTH AFRICA.
WOW.
BUT YOU GUYS
HAVE TO PACK TONIGHT.
ARE YOU READY?
YES!
ALL RIGHTY.
LET'S DO IT.
WHOO!
LET'S GO TO AFRICA!
SOUTH AFRICA!
WHOO!
♪♪♪
KEENYAH, HERE'S YOUR DRESS.
I GONNA
JUST DUMP EVERYTHING OUT
AND START OVER.
WE ARE GOING TO AFRICA.
WE HAVE TWO HOURS TO PACK,
HAVE TO BRING EVERYTHING.
DO NOT LEAVE A SOCK
IF YOU WANT THAT SOCK BACK.
IS THAT ACTUALLY WORKING?
I THINK SO.
ONCE WE GET TO AFRICA,
THE COMPETITION IS GONNA BE
OUT OF THIS WORLD.
ANYTHING CAN HAPPEN,
AND WE'LL HAVE TO KEEP
OUR EYES ON THE PRIZE.
GOOD-BYE, L.A.
♪♪♪
(singing in African language)
IT'S, LIKE,
A REALLY LONG FLIGHT,
AND THEN
WHEN WE FINALLY GET HERE,
IT'S BEAUTIFUL.
WE SEE MOUNTAINS
AND IT'S SUNNY AND IT'S HOT.
WE HAVE TO WALK LIKE THIS.
WE'RE LIKE, OH, MY GOSH,
WE CAN'T BELIEVE
WE'RE IN AFRICA.
CAN YOU BELIEVE IT?
WE'RE ON AFRICAN DIRT.
LIKE, IT'S CRAZY.
BRITTANY AND KEENYAH JOKE
ALL THE TIME.
I AM NOT USED TO OPENING UP
TO PEOPLE,
AND I HAVE BEEN TRYING TO
CONNECT WITH THEM MORE.
BUT I'M PART OF THE GROUP,
BUT NOT, LIKE,
A MAJOR PART OF THE GROUP.
DID YOU READ THE PACKET?
IT SAID WHEN YOU'RE
IN CONVERSATION,
DON'T PUT YOUR HANDS
IN YOUR POCKET,
BECAUSE THAT'S RUDE.
LOOK THEM IN THE EYE
AND DON'T POINT
WITH YOUR INDEX FINGER.
REALLY?
WELL, THAT'S THE SAME RULE
AS IN AMERICA,
IT'S JUST NOT WRITTEN DOWN.
SO THIS IS NOT GOOD?
WE CAN'T DO THAT
IN AMERICA EITHER.
I FEEL LIKE BRITTANY
AND KEENYAH JUST JOKE,
BECAUSE, YOU KNOW,
EVERY TIME I SAY SOMETHING,
IT'S LIKE,
"OH, THAT'S FUNNY.
LET'S MAKE FUN OF IT."
SOMETIMES YOU GET
REALLY TIRED OF THAT.
WE ARE IN CAPE TOWN.
WE NEED, LIKE, AFRICAN MUSIC,
SOME DRUM BEATS, SOMETHING.
(humming)
♪♪♪
I STILL CAN'T BELIEVE
WE'RE HERE IN SOUTH AFRICA,
BUT WHERE ARE WE GOING?
GOOD AFTERNOON, LADIES.
WELCOME TO AQUILA.
WELCOME TO SOUTH AFRICA.
I'M PIERRE,
THE MANAGER AT THE RESERVE.
FOLLOW ME.
THANK YOU.
WE SEE THE DRUMMERS
IN THE DISTANCE, AND I WENT,
LIKE, "YEAH, THIS IS TOUGH,
THIS IS HIP."
THIS IS JUST A TASTE OF WHAT
SOUTH AFRICA HAS TO OFFER.
OH!
AAH!
ALL OF A SUDDEN
TYRA RUNS IN BEHIND US,
AND WE'RE LIKE,
"OH, TYRA--SHE'S HERE!"
LIKE, SHE ALWAYS POPS UP
AT, LIKE, THE WEIRDEST TIMES.
HI!
HI, TYRA!
WELCOME TO SOUTH AFRICA!
ISN'T IT BEAUTIFUL?
YES.
SO LET ME TELL YOU
A LITTLE BIT
ABOUT WHY YOU'RE HERE.
IN SOUTH AFRICA,
FASHION WEEK IS HUGE.
THEY HAVE
AFRICAN-TYPE DESIGNERS,
YOU KNOW, FOR, LIKE,
THE TRADITIONAL GARB,
ALL THE WAY TO HAUTE COUTURE.
THIS IS NOW
A PLACE FOR NEW MODELS
TO COME TO MAKE IT.
I HAD MY VERY FIRST COVER
OF "SPORTS ILLUSTRATED"
SHOT HERE IN SOUTH AFRICA.
THEY HAVE
SOUTH AFRICAN "COSMOPOLITAN,"
SOUTH AFRICAN "ELLE,"
AND THEIR OWN LOCAL MAGAZINES.
NONE OF US GIRLS
HAD ANY IDEA THAT SOUTH AFRICA
WAS DEVELOPING ITSELF IN
THE FASHION INDUSTRY WHATSOEVER.
OH, MY GOD.
WHEN THE HELL DID THIS HAPPEN?
SO YOU GUYS ARE GONNA BE
EXPERIENCING A LOT HERE,
AND HOPEFULLY HAVING
LOTS OF PICTURES TO TAKE HOME.
SO CAN WE GET
A LITTLE GROOVE ON?
YEAH!
♪♪♪
THESE DANCERS
COME RUNNING OUT
IN THEIR LITTLE
CHEETAH OUTFITS.
I DON'T KNOW
WHAT THE HELL IS GOING ON.
AAH!
I FELT LIKE
IT WAS A SHARK FRENZY.
THEY'RE SLOWLY
CIRCLING AROUND US,
TYRA GRABS MY HAND
AND THROWS ME IN THE LINE.
I'M, LIKE, "OKAY, FINE,
I'LL DO IT.
♪♪♪
BYE.
NEXT THING I KNOW,
TYRA'S JUST MISSING.
TYRA JUST KIND OF CREEPS OUT.
"BYE, GIRLS."
SHE'S OUT. QUICKNESS.
GOOD AFTERNOON, LADIES.
WE'RE GOING TO TAKE YOU
ON A LITTLE SAFARI.
ALL RIGHT.
OH, YEAH.
PIERRE TELLS US WE'RE GOING
ON A SAFARI,
AND I AM GOING THROUGH
THE ROOF.
I AM DEFINITELY
LOOKING FORWARD TO THIS.
ALL RIGHT. THANK YOU.
HIPPO IN THE WATER,
EVERYBODY.
HIPPO!
OH, I DO SEE HIM.
OOH! HE'S LOOKING
FOR MARBLES.
DO YOU KNOW HOW MANY TONS
THEY WEIGH?
NO. 2?
NO. HOW MANY?
ABOUT 1 1/2 TONS.
WOW.
SAME AMOUNT AS KEENYAH.
OH HO!
I'M JUST KIDDING.
GLUTTONY!
KEENYAH'S GLUTTONY
PHOTO SHOOT,
SHE MAKES A JOKE OUT OF IT,
WHICH IS GREAT.
IT'S HILARIOUS.
I DON'T WANNA FALL OUT
OR THE HIPPO IS GONNA EAT ME
FOR LUNCH.
THE THING ABOUT MY WEIGHT,
I FEEL LIKE I CAN STILL DO THIS
BECAUSE YOANNA
HAD PROBLEMS WITH HER WEIGHT,
AND SHE ENDED UP WINNING
THE COMPETITION.
I DON'T APPROVE
OF THIS CONVERSATION
BECAUSE I'M NOT IN IT.
♪ THE BRITTANY SHOW ♪♪
LOOK AT HOW BEAUTIFUL
THAT LOOKS.
GIRAFFE.
IT'S A MOM AND HER DAUGHTER.
WHERE?
WHERE ARE THEY?
AND I'LL TELL YOU THE QUESTION--
CAN I RIDE ONE OF 'EM?
CAN I RUN OUT THERE
WITH THE BUFFALO?
CAN YOU GRAZE WITH THEM?
YOU GO RIGHT AHEAD,
BRITTANY.
THAT'S WHAT KILLED MUFASA.
HOLY SHIMOLYS!
LOOK AT THOSE RHINOS.
RHINOS! WE'VE GOT RHINOS.
OH, LOOK AT 'EM.
LOOK AT 'EM.
ARE THOSE ALL SPRINGBOKS?
THEY'RE ALL SPRINGBOKS.
GOSH.
A LOT OF THE ANIMALS
ON THE SAFARI,
THEY JUST SAT THERE, CHILLED.
I WANTED TO SEE SOME ACTION.
HAVE THERE BEEN ANY ATTACKS?
NOT YET.
WE'RE ABOUT TO ENTER
THE LION ZONE,
AND WE CAN'T MAKE ANY NOISE.
AND WE ALL AUTOMATICALLY
LOOK TO BRITTANY.
WHAT ARE YOU LOOKING AT?
WHAT?
THEY KNOW SOMEBODY'S
GONNA SAY SOMETHING.
ABOUT WHAT?
ONCE IT GETS EYE CONTACT
WITH BRITTANY, I'M OUTTA HERE.
I AM OUT OF HERE.
I'LL BE BEATING 'EM DOWN.
I AM NOT GETTING ATTACKED
BEFORE ELIMINATION
BECAUSE OF BRITTANY.
I AM NOT. I REFUSE TO.
SO IF WE'RE RUNNING AWAY
FROM A LION,
AND WE GET ATTACKED,
THERE'S NO WAY OUT?
EXACTLY.
RIGHT.
DO WE HAVE TO BE QUIET NOW?
PARDON ME?
DO WE HAVE TO BE QUIET?
YES.
OH, MY GOD!
I'M LIKE, "OKAY."
WE WERE REALLY ON A SAFARI,
BUT, JEEZ, LIKE, THE LIONS
COULD ATTACK US.
THERE'S NOTHING
BLOCKING THEM FROM US
IF THEY WANTED
TO HAVE US FOR DINNER.
I CAN'T SING OR DANCE
RIGHT NOW?
SHH.
IS THERE NO SINGING
AND DANCING PAST THIS POINT?
(whispers)
BRITTANY, STOP.
THEY'RE GETTING UP.
OH, THEY'RE GETTING UP.
WE'RE EYEING THEM,
AREN'T WE?
(engine revs)
(horn honks)
OH, MY GOD.
WE'RE EYING THEM,
AREN'T WE?
(whispers)
WHY ARE YOU--
RAWR.
THE LIONS,
THEY'RE VERY DANGEROUS.
BE VERY, VERY QUIET,
DON'T MAKE
ANY SUDDEN MOVEMENTS,
AND BRITTANY
IS NOT AFRAID OF THIS.
I HAVE NO IDEA WHY.
WE ARE LIKE,
"BRITTANY, SHUT UP!"
(engine revs)
(horn honks)
OH, MY GOD.
OH, MY GOD. NEVER AGAIN.
IT WAS BRITTANY'S FAULT.
I WANNA GO BACK
AND DO THAT AGAIN.
I COULD HAVE SWORN
WE WERE ABOUT TO GET ATTACKED.
SHE WAS LIKE...
OH, NO. OH, NO.
♪♪♪
SO WE'RE DRIVING ALONG,
AND IT'S GETTING REALLY DARK.
WE SEE A FIRE,
AND WE'RE ALL THINKING,
"OH, GOD, MAYBE THIS
IS A PHOTO SHOOT."
WE HAVE NO IDEA.
I UNDERSTAND THAT
THERE HAS BEEN SOME CHALLENGE.
AND WHO IS THE WINNER?
ME!
AND WHO DID YOU PICK?
THESE TWO.
OKAY, CONGRATULATIONS, GUYS.
WE'RE STAYING
OUT HERE.
THANK YOU.
YOU ARE GOING BACK WITH ME.
YOU ARE GOING TO STAY IN ONE
OF OUR LUXURY ACCOMMODATIONS.
AND THE OTHER GUYS--
THEY ARE GOING
TO STAY RIGHT HERE.
WHOO!
BUT YOU HAVE TO BUILD
YOUR OWN TENT.
OOH.
I HAVE TO BUILD
MY OWN TENT?
WOW.
OKAY, UM,
IS THIS THAT OUR TENT?
THANK GOD
I WATCHED "SURVIVOR."
HOW LONG AM I GONNA BE
OUT HERE?
I HAVE NEVER GONE CAMPING.
ALL THESE QUESTIONS START
GOING THROUGH MY HEAD LIKE,
UM, BLOW DRYER, HOT IRON.
MY HAIR IS GONNA FRIZZ.
WE LOVE YOU GIRLS,
BUT WE GOTTA GO.
GOOD NIGHT.
SO, LADIES, LET'S START
BUILDING OUR SHELTER.
MICHELLE'S ALWAYS, LIKE,
"THIS IS GONNA BE AWESOME,"
AND I APPRECIATE
THAT QUALITY IN HER,
BUT I THINK A LOT OF THAT
IS HER WANTING TO APPEAR
STRONG TO OTHER PEOPLE.
OH, THIS ISN'T
GONNA BE THAT BAD.
OH! OH, MY GOD. OH!
THAT WAS, LIKE, A ROACH
OR SOMETHING.
I DON'T KNOW.
(laughing)
THAT IS NOT FUNNY.
BYE, GIRLS.
BYE.
LOVE YOU, KAHLEN.
LOVE YOU, NAIMA.
LOVE YOU, MICHELLE.
WELCOME, LADIES.
WOW.
HERE'S YOUR ROOM
FOR THE EVENING.
TO A LUXURIOUS NIGHT
IN AFRICA.
LET'S SAY IT TOGETHER.
WE ARE NOT
OUT IN THE WILDERNESS.
CHEERS TO THAT.
HOW MANY MODELS DOES IT TAKE
TO PEE IN THE WILDERNESS?
TWO?
CAN YOU GET ME
SOME TOILET PAPER?
THERE IS NO WAY
THAT MY ANCESTORS DID THIS.
IT'S A GOOD THING THAT
THE HIGH-MAINTENANCE GIRLS
GET TO STAY
IN THE 5-STAR HOTEL,
BECAUSE THEY NEVER
WOULD HAVE SURVIVED.
I WONDER WHAT
THE OTHER GIRLS ARE DOING.
OH, EATING STRAWBERRIES
AND CHOCOLATE, CHAMPAGNE--
IN THE JACUZZI.
THERE'S ROSE PETALS
IN THE HOT TUB.
OH, AND LITTLE FRIENDS.
LITTLE FRIENDS
AREN'T STILL ALIVE.
AAH!
OH, GROSS.
OH! OKAY, I'M DONE.
NATURE MEETS BEVERLY HILLS.
I JUST DON'T LIKE BUGS
VERY MUCH.
I CAN'T TAKE THESE BUGS.
AAH!
WE'RE BEING TORTURED!
(laughs)
THIS IS NOT A VACATION.
WE'RE REALLY ROUGHING IT.
OH, GET OUT OF THE BED.
GET, GET.
AAH!
OH! GET OUT OF HERE!
OH, THERE'S A COCKROACH!
ON YOUR PILLOW?
WHAT THE HELL?
ARE YOU JOKING?
YOU KNOW,
IF WE ARE GETTING EATEN UP,
I DON'T EVEN KNOW
HOW THE OTHER GIRLS ARE.
♪♪♪
IS THAT A SNAKE?
OH! OH!
(laughing)
THAT SCARED ME SO MUCH.
GOOD MORNING.
GOOD MORNING, LADIES.
WELCOME BACK.
THERE'S A NICE,
HOT BREAKFAST
WAITING FOR YOU
IN THE RESTAURANT.
OH, I LOVE YOU!
THANK YOU.
ALL RIGHT.
WELL, HEY THERE, LADIES.
HOW WAS YOUR NIGHT?
IT WAS ROUGH.
THANK YOU.
THAT'S A LOT.
CAN YOU TELL?
NO.
A LITTLE BIT?
WHEN I'M UNDER
A LOT OF STRESS,
I FIND A REAL COMFORT
IN EATING.
KEENYAH--SHE FEELS LIKE
SHE GAINING SOME WEIGHT,
BUT WHEN THE NEXT BREAD TRAY
COMES AROUND,
SHE'LL BE THE FIRST ONE TO GRAB
A CROISSANT OR TWO OFF OF IT.
I THINK I'D LIKE
A BOWL OF THAT YOGURT.
KEENYAH--
JUST FILLING UP MORE.
IT'S JUST YOGURT.
SHE SAYS SHE WANTS
TO LOSE WEIGHT
AND SHE WANTS HELP.
WELL, IF I'M GONNA HELP,
SHE'S GETTIN' RIBBED.
YOGURT!
OH, LOOK WHO IT IS.
HEY, GIRLS, COME OVER HERE.
WOW.
WHOO!
SO YOU GUYS LEARNED
ALL ABOUT POSING LIKE ANIMALS.
SO, OF COURSE, WE'RE GONNA DO
A PHOTO SHOOT TODAY,
BUT YOU GUYS ARE GOING TO BE
THE ANIMALS.
SO I PICKED AN ANIMAL
THAT I THINK REPRESENTS EACH
AND ALL OF YOU.
I'M GONNA START WITH YOU,
THEN, KAHLEN.
YOU ARE ACTUALLY GOING TO BE
A SPRINGBOK.
SPRINGBOK IS
SOUTH AFRICA'S NATIONAL ANIMAL.
CHRISTINA, YOU'RE GONNA BE
AN OSTRICH.
OH, WOW.
BRITTANY, YOU ARE
SO TALL AND LONG,
YOU'RE GONNA BE...
A GIRAFFE!
A GIRAFFE.
MICHELLE, WE'RE GONNA
MAKE YOU A ZEBRA.
OH, THERE WE GO!
I THINK THAT'S APPROPRIATE
BECAUSE ZEBRAS
ARE KIND OF SKITTISH
AND KIND OF AFRAID.
NAIMA, SILENT PREDATOR...
OH, NO.
CHEETAH.
A CHEETAH.
ALL RIGHT?
OKAY.
KEENYAH, YOU GET TO BE
THE ELEPHANT.
I DON'T KNOW HOW--
(laughter)
ONE WEEK IT'S GLUTTONY,
THE NEXT WEEK IT'S AN ELEPHANT.
RIGHT.
EVERYBODY ELSE HAS
THESE SEXY LITTLE ANIMALS,
AND I GET TO BE
THE BIG, FAT ELEPHANT.
WHY DO I KEEP
GETTING STUCK WITH
THESE FAT, LIKE, CHARACTERS?
WHAT IS GOING ON?
OH, IS THAT A GATOR?
WHERE?
RIGHT THERE.
WOW.
OH, REALLY?
OH, MY GOD.
ALL RIGHT,
SO TODAY'S SHOOT
IS FOR LUBRIDERM
ULTRA-MOISTURIZING LOTION
WITH PREMIUM OAT EXTRACTS,
AND, OF COURSE, THAT'S WHY
WE'VE GOT THE CROCODILE.
SO I WANT TO INTRODUCE YOU
TO YOUR PHOTOGRAPHER.
HER NAME IS GERDA.
GERDA, YOU WANNA COME OUT
AND MEET THE GIRLS?
HI, GIRLS.
HI.
THEY'RE BEAUTIFUL, RIGHT?
WONDERFUL.
WE GOTTA GET YOU GUYS
BACK TO HAIR AND MAKEUP,
TURN YOU INTO SOME ANIMALS.
YOU'RE A SEXY ZEBRA.
THINK TRUNK.
TRUNK?
TRUNK.
HAVE YOU BEEN THINKING
ABOUT OSTRICHES
WHILE YOU'VE BEEN
IN HAIR AND MAKEUP?
YES.
NOW AND YOU'RE WORKING
WITH MARY OBVIOUSLY.
YES.
SO I DON'T WANT TO
SEE NERVES.
'CAUSE, YOU KNOW,
THE COMPETITION'S GETTING
SO TIGHT...
IT IS.
WHO'S GONNA BE ELIMINATED
IS REALLY DEPENDENT
ON THIS PHOTO SHOOT, OKAY?
GOT IT.
CABARET LIKE.
GOOD, YES.
PRETTY.
OH, I LOVE THAT.
BEAUTIFUL, ELEGANT, YES.
IF WE COULD JUST HAVE
A LITTLE MORE WARMTH
IN THE FACE?
THINK OF
SOMETHING PLEASANT,
LIKE LOLLIPOPS
IN THE AFTERNOON.
(laughs)
ANYTHING?
WHAT ABOUT YOUR HEAD
IN MARY'S MOUTH?
YES!
YES! OH, MY GOD. YES!
FOR THE FIRST TIME, WE GOT
REAL EMOTION OUT OF HER.
I THINK THIS IS CHRISTINA'S
BEST SHOOT SO FAR.
YEAH, THERE YOU GO.
YES!
OH, MY GOD.
ANOTHER SMILE.
ALL RIGHT, MY DEAR.
GO AHEAD AND WORK IT.
I WALKED IN THE SHOOT
FEELING AMAZING.
I WAS READY TO
HOP UP THERE ON THAT ROCK
WITH THE ALLIGATOR
AND JUST DO MY THING.
WHOA. WHOA. WHOA.
THAT'S LOOKING
A BIT LIKE A CRANE
AND LESS LIKE A ZEBRA.
THINK MORE GRACEFUL
'CAUSE YOU DO THIS A LOT.
BETTER.
RELAX.
DON'T FORGET YOUR NECK,
MICHELLE.
EVERY SHOOT TO DATE, I HAVE
TOLD MICHELLE TO DROP HER CHIN
AND TRUST THE EYE LINE
FROM HER EYE TO THE CAMERA.
THAT LOOKS GREAT.
IF YOU JUST HOLD THAT
AND WORK THAT,
THAT'D BE PERFECT.
LOVELY. LOVE THAT.
NAIMA--SHE POSES RIGHT DOWN
TO THE TIPPY TOES OF HER FEET.
BEAUTIFUL.
A LITTLE SMIRK.
YOU THINK OF EVERYTHING
AND YOU FORGET THE MOUTH.
THAT'S ONE THING.
SHE'S THE SILENT KILLER.
HOW COME YOU JUST
GET TO CRAWL AROUND
AND I GOTTA WORK
WITH A CANE?
I DIDN'T QUITE LIKE MY LOOK,
BUT I REALLY WANT
THIS PHOTO SHOOT
TO PULL THROUGH AND BRING ME
ANOTHER GREAT PICTURE.
IT COULD BE WORSE.
YOU COULD BE AN ELEPHANT.
I'M FREAKING OUT.
LIKE,
"WHAT AM I GONNA DO?"
I DON'T KNOW HOW TO BE
A SEXY ELEPHANT.
THE STOMACH IS EXPOSED
TO THE HIGHEST EXTENT,
AND IT'S BLOATED, AND IT
DOESN'T LOOK GOOD AT ALL.
I HAVE TO JUST TRY
TO SUCK IT IN AND WORK IT.
THINK OF YOUR ARM AS
AN EXTENSION OF YOUR NOSE.
IT'S GOT TO BE IN YOUR MIND,
THEN WE'LL BELIEVE IT.
THINK OF IT, KEENYAH.
RIGHT NOW
YOU'RE JUST HOLDING IT.
NOW YOU'RE HOLDING
THAT BOTTLE AGAIN.
IT'S NOT A TRUNK.
THAT'S MY TENTH TIME.
KEENYAH--SHE JUST
KIND OF POSES
AND JUST HOPES
THAT IT WORKS.
THAT'S NOT
THE BEST WAY TO MODEL.
♪♪♪
IT DOESN'T HAVE TO GET
TOO STIFF.
YOU'RE A CUDDLY,
TALL GIRAFFE.
BRITTANY--I KNOW SHE HAD
A LOT TO DEAL WITH,
BUT SHE
WASN'T AS AWARE OF HER FACE.
YOU'RE GETTING
A LITTLE STILTED.
A LITTLE SMILE, YES.
IN MIDDLE SCHOOL,
I WAS ALWAYS CALLED GIRAFFE.
IT HURT MY FEELINGS.
SO IT'S JUST KINDA FUN NOW
TO BE A SEXY GIRAFFE
AND BE LIKE, "HA!"
OOH, YES.
THAT'S NICE. YES.
THAT'S GREAT.
KAHLEN,
IT'S COMING FOR YOU.
OUR SPRINGBOK.
IT'S NOT A DEER,
IT'S A SPRINGBOK.
YES. YES.
THAT'S GREAT, KAHLEN.
WHAT ARE YOU DOING
WITH THE HAND IN THE MIDDLE?
I'M CURIOUS.
LIKE, I JUST DON'T GET
WHAT THIS IS.
WHOO!
THAT--THAT'S MUCH BETTER.
YES, NICE.
OOH, I ACTUALLY LOVE THAT.
NICE, YES!
KAHLEN DID THE BEST JOB
OF TAKING ON HER ANIMAL.
I TOLD HER,
IF ANYTHING HAPPENS,
LET GO OF
THELUBRIDERM AND GO,
AND SHE JUST SPLIT OUTTA THERE
LIKE A SPRINGBOK WOULD.
THEY KINDA
PRANCE AND BOUNCE.
(laughs)
JAWS.
♪♪♪
IT'S OUR FIRST NIGHT OUT
TO DINNER IN SOUTH AFRICA,
AND WE WERE GOING TO
A RESTAURANT CALLED FIVE FLIES.
IT'S BEEN A LONG DAY
OUT IN THE SUN.
WE'RE HAPPY TO EAT.
I WENT ON THE SET,
AND THEN JAY HANDS ME
THE LUBRIDERM BOTTLE,
AND I WENT LIKE THIS...
HONEST TO GOD.
I THOUGHT HE WAS
JUST HANDING ME LOTION.
AND HE WAS LIKE,
"NO, THIS IS WHAT
YOU'RE MODELING, HONEY."
I'M LIKE...
(laughter)
MICHELLE,
DO YOU FEEL ALIENATED?
NAIMA--I'M SURPRISED
WHEN SHE SAYS THAT.
I MEAN, IT WAS KINDA
OUTTA THE BLUE.
I DON'T WANT TO
SAY ANYTHING,
BECAUSE
IT'S NOT PURELY THEM.
IT'S MOSTLY ME.
I MEAN, I HAVE HAD
A HARD TIME WITH IT,
BUT, I MEAN, I'M TRYING TO GET
MORE IN WITH THE GROUP.
BUT YOU'VE BEEN
AROUND US SO LONG, MICHELLE.
YOU SHOULDN'T FEEL
THE NEED TO BE DISTANT.
I'M JUST KIND OF
OVER MICHELLE AT THIS POINT.
I FEEL, IF YOU'RE NOT GONNA
GET IN WITH US
SINCE WE'VE BEEN HERE,
THAT I JUST DON'T FEEL LIKE
IT'S GONNA HAPPEN NOW.
WAITING FOR MAIL?
OH, THANK YOU SO MUCH.
"YOU'VE BEEN OUT
WHERE THE LIONS ROAM.
"NOW HEAD OUT
TO YOUR SEASIDE HOME.
TYRA."
PSYCH. IT SAYS...
NO, IT REALLY SAYS
"YOUR SEASIDE HOME."
♪♪♪
ROOM READY?
WHOO-HOO!
WHOO!
VERY, VERY GROOVY, BABY.
OUR HOTEL SUITE IS
REALLY, REALLY NICE.
WE ARE ON THE WATER,
AND TO ME,
THE OCEAN IS SO CALMING,
AND ESPECIALLY IN A SITUATION
WHERE WE'RE SO STRESSED.
THIS IS PHAT,
AND THAT MEANS WITH A "P-H."
I DON'T NEED YOU
TO FINGER ALL OF THE CANDY.
TYRA MAIL!
"TOMORROW YOU WILL MEET
WITH THE JUDGES.
"ONLY FIVE OF YOU
WILL CONTINUE
"IN THE HOPES OF BECOMING
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL.
ONE OF YOU
WILL BE ELIMINATED."
I FEEL LIKE MY STANDING
IN THE COMPETITION
IS PRETTY STRONG,
BUT THEN AGAIN,
I COULD BE WRONG BECAUSE
EVERY TIME I GO TO PANEL,
IT'S ANOTHER PROBLEM
THAT THEY PRESENT.
I'M STILL PART ELEPHANT.
I HAVE SOME NERVES
WORKING UP INSIDE OF ME.
I WOULD BE INSANE
IF I DIDN'T.
I AM PRAYING
THAT MY PHOTO IS GOOD.
♪♪♪
WELCOME TO YOUR VERY FIRST
SOUTH AFRICAN JUDGING
EXPERIENCE.
NOW IT'S TIME TO MAKE
OUR NINTH CUT,
WHICH WILL BRING US
ONE STEP CLOSER
TOWARDS DETERMINING
WHO WILL BECOME
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL.
NOW YOU GUYS KNOW
ABOUT THE FABULOUS PRIZES--
A CONTRACT FROM TOP
INTERNATIONAL
MODEL MANAGEMENT
COMPANY, FORD MODELS,
A PHOTO SPREAD
IN "ELLE" MAGAZINE,
WHICH WILL BE SHOT BY
WORLD-RENOWNED PHOTOGRAPHER
GILLES BENSIMONE,
AND A $100,000 CONTRACT
WITH COVER GIRL COSMETICS.
WE HAVE OUR AMAZING JUDGES,
THE FIRST BEING
MISS JANICE DICKINSON,
ONE OF THE WORLD'S FIRST
SUPERMODELS,
NIGEL BARKER,
NOTED FASHION PHOTOGRAPHER,
NOLE MARIN, PROMINENT
FASHION EDITOR AND STYLIST,
AND GERDA,
WHO WAS YOUR PHOTOGRAPHER
THIS WEEK
FOR YOUR PHOTO SHOOT.
THIS WEEK YOU LEARNED
ALL ABOUT POSING,
SO TODAY WE'RE GONNA TEST YOU
ON YOUR POSING SKILLS.
THE JUDGES HAVE
FIVE DIFFERENT OBJECTS
HIDDEN
UNDERNEATH THIS TABLE.
THE JUDGES ARE GONNA
HAND YOU A OBJECT
AND GIVE YOU A WORD
THAT YOU HAVE TO ACT OUT.
YOU HAVE ONE POSE
PER OBJECT.
YOU HAVE TO STRIKE IT FAST,
AND YOU HAVE TO
STRIKE IT STRONG.
WORK IT, GIRLFRIEND.
WORK IT.
YOUR EMOTION,
MY DEAR--ANGER.
JUST ANY TIME?
NO, WAIT AN HOUR.
♪♪♪
(trumpet plays
"Wah-Wah" sound)
♪♪♪
AND THIS NEXT IS FEAR.
(sneaky music playing)
ALOOF.
WHAT IS ALOOF?
COULD I HAVE A HINT?
ALOOF.
ALOOF?
I CAN'T ASK WHAT ALOOF IS?
NO.
THERE YOU GO.
PASSION.
(funk music playing)
(music slows and stops)
HERE YOU GO, MICHELLE.
HAPPINESS.
(ragtime music playing)
(laughter)
NOW WE'RE GONNA DO
YOUR INDIVIDUAL EVALUATIONS.
FIRST IS MICHELLE.
YOUR BEST POSE WAS FEAR.
YOU LOOKED QUITE SCARED
THE WHOLE TIME.
YOU HAD A PHOTO SHOOT WHERE
YOU HAD TO EVOKE AN ANIMAL--
THE LOOK, THE TOUCH,
THE FEEL, THE SMELL--
NOT THE SMELL.
AND HERE IS YOUR BEST SHOT.
WOW.
YOU WERE SCARED
IN FRONT OF US,
GIVING US THE EMOTIONS,
YET SOMEHOW YOU MANAGED
TO PULL OFF SORT OF PASSION
AND LUST WITH AN ALLIGATOR
BETWEEN YOUR LEGS.
I LIKE THIS SHOT.
I DON'T LOVE IT,
BUT I REALLY LIKE IT.
IT'S NOT GOOD ENOUGH!
YOU'RE NOT PORTRAYING
AN ANIMAL.
YOU WERE BORN WITH
BEAUTIFUL LOOKS,
BUT IT'S A HELL OF A LOT MORE
THAN THAT, HONEY.
NAIMA.
WHEN YOU WERE POSING,
YOU WERE ALMOST THERE,
LIKE OUT OF TEN YOU WERE LIKE
EIGHT AND A HALF, NINE.
PASSION.
I DIDN'T FIND IT.
CAN YOU DO PASSION?
OOH.
BUT SEE THE FACE--
THE FACE GOT UGLY.
YOU DID ELVIS.
HERE IS YOUR BEST SHOT.
SHE'S A CHEETAH.
- AMAZING.
- WELL DONE.
I WOULD LOVE TO HAVE SEEN
YOUR RIGHT LEG
NOT LOOK LIKE AN AMPUTEE.
I THINK THE LEG IS FINE.
UNFORTUNATELY,
I AGREE WITH JANICE.
I THINK THE BODY COULD HAVE
MORE ELEGANCE.
COME ON, YOU GUYS,
WHAT DO YOU SEE?
SHE'S BEING AN ANIMAL
AND A MODEL AT THE SAME TIME.
SHE WAS THE ONE PERSON
THAT USED HER LIMBS
LIKE THE ANIMAL,
AND THAT'S BRILLIANT.
KEENYAH.
YOU HAVE TO MODEL
WITH YOUR WHOLE BODY.
THE OTHER GIRLS
GOT ON THE GROUND,
GOT UP, MOVED AROUND,
HELD THINGS IN THE AIR.
YOU WERE LIKE THIS
THE WHOLE TIME.
ALOOF AND PASSION WERE
EXACTLY THE SAME THING.
IT WAS LIKE GROUNDHOG'S DAY.
WOW.
- WOW, WHAT?
- BEAUTIFUL FACE.
THIS IS A BEAUTIFUL SHOT,
AND IT HAS AN ELEGANCE
THAT ELEPHANTS HAVE
DESPITE THEIR HEAVINESS.
THIS PHOTO IS
REALLY BEAUTIFUL, KEENYAH,
BUT I HATE TO SAY IT--
THEY HAD TO DO
A LOT OF BODY WORK ON YOU
IN RETOUCHING.
AT HOME, PRETTY MUCH I TRY
TO, YOU KNOW, EAT RIGHT,
AND WE COME HERE,
MY METABOLISM,
EVERYTHING IS THROWN OFF.
STOP!
IF YOU'RE SPORTING A GUT,
THEN YOU TURN TO THE SIDE
AND DISGUISE IT.
KEENYAH, IN THE REAL WORLD,
YOU'RE A THIN GIRL,
BUT THE FASHION INDUSTRY
IS SO EXTREME,
AND I WOULD LOVE TO CHANGE
THE RULES,
BUT UNTIL THAT HAPPENS,
I THINK IT'S ALL
ABOUT CHOICES, KEENYAH.
YOU CAN GET A BURGER
AND TAKE THE BREAD OFF.
I MAKE IT WORK
WHEN I HAVE TO.
THANK YOU.
NOW I CAN EAT
WHATEVER THE HELL I WANT.
THEY'LL RETOUCH IT, YOU KNOW,
BECAUSE I PAID MY DUES.
I SAW YOU EATING
THOSE BURGERS.
I DO. I EAT.
SHE EATS THOSE RIBS.
YOU'RE NEW.
BE HONEST WITH YOURSELF
AND DON'T POINT THE FINGER,
BECAUSE NOBODY WILL
RETOUCH A PICTURE
AS MUCH
AS WE DID THIS PICTURE.
CHRISTINA, I THOUGHT
YOUR HAPPINESS LOOKED CRAZY,
LIKE, "HEH-HEH-HEH!
I'M GONNA GETCHA!"
YOU KNOW?
YOU LOOKED INSANE.
AND YOUR PASSION,
IT WAS LIKE,
WHO'S TURNING YOU ON, MAN?
'CAUSE HE DON'T KNOW
WHAT HE'S DOING.
OH, MY GOODNESS.
THIS WAS AN OSTRICH.
THE LEGS ARE AMAZING,
BEAUTIFUL ARMS.
THIS IS THE BEST PICTURE
YOU'VE EVER TAKEN.
BUT YOUR WEAK SPOT
IS YOUR MOUTH.
YOUR TOP LIP COULD BE
A LITTLE FULLER.
THERE'S A TRICK.
LET ME SHOW YOU.
PEOPLE TELL YOU
YOU NEED SURGERY.
YOU DON'T NEED SURGERY.
UNDERNEATH YOUR TOP LIP,
STUFF THAT IN THERE.
THIS IS WHAT
THE INDUSTRY IS ALL ABOUT--
CHICKEN CUTLETS
FOR THE BREASTS.
EVEN MEN STICK FAKE PENISES
DOWN THERE FOR UNDERWEAR JOBS.
OH! LOOK AT IT.
LOOK AT IT.
OH, MY GOD.
IT'S GORGEOUS.
THIS IS YOUR TRICK.
BRITTANY.
BRITTANY WON THE POSING
CHALLENGE WITH MISS J.
YOU MIGHT HAVE WON IT
IN LOS ANGELES,
BUT THIS WAS JUST LIKE--
WHAT WAS THAT?
WE'VE TOLD YOU
TIME AND TIME AGAIN
JUST HOW GORGEOUS YOU ARE
WHEN YOU ARE QUIET AND SIMPLE,
DOING JUST THAT.
RIGHT NOW.
IT'S ALLURING
AND NOT WHORING.
THAT WAS THE KEY WORD THERE.
WOW, LOOK AT THAT.
AH, YOU ROCKED IT.
IT'S FANTASTIC.
BRITTANY,
DO YOU SEE YOUR FACE,
HOW PEACEFUL IT IS,
AND IT'S NATURALLY SEXY?
KAHLEN.
I MUST SAY, GIRL,
YOU ROCKED.
YOU WERE ABSOLUTELY AMAZING.
YOU COMMITTED SO MUCH
LIKE A PRO.
BUT THEN YOU GOT TO PASSION,
AND YOU KNOW WHAT TO DO,
BUT I FELT LIKE
YOU'RE HOLDING BACK
'CAUSE THAT'S TOO SEXY.
SO I WANNA SEE PASSION
RIGHT NOW.
NO, NOT POUTY--PASSION.
LET'S DO IT TOGETHER,
JANICE.
THIS IS PASSION.
IT'S SOMETHING THAT'S
SO EXAGGERATED, YOU GUYS.
YOU WANT TO SEE PASSION?
AAH!
(laughing)
I'LL SHOW YOU PASSION.
PERHAPS I CAN GET INVOLVED.
HELP!
JUST KIDDING. WAIT, WAIT!
PASSION!
(laughter)
CHILD.
IT'S JUST GIRLS HAVING FUN.
ALL RIGHT.
THAT'S PASSION.
YOU CAN'T HOLD BACK.
THAT WAS SCARY.
ALL RIGHT,
HERE IS YOUR BEST SHOT.
WILD KINGDOM, HERE WE COME.
YOU ARE A CHAMELEON.
YOU HAVE THE ABILITY
TO TURN INTO ANYTHING
AND EVERYTHING.
IT'S NOT SEXY,
BUT IT'S VERY COOL.
WERE YOU AFRAID
OF THE CROC?
SHE FELL ON TOP OF HIM.
YOU FELL ON THE CROC?
AND I RAN FASTER
THAN A SPRINGBOK.
GIRL, THAT'S A DRAG QUEEN
AFTER MY OWN HEART--
A GIRL IN
HIGH HEELS RUNNING.
(laughing)
NAIMA.
SHE LOOKS AMAZING
IN THIS PICTURE.
SHE WEARS THE SPOTS
OF A LEOPARD VERY WELL.
BUT I THINK
NAIMA HOLDS BACK A LOT.
BRITTANY.
BRITTANY HAS WHAT IT TAKES
TO BE A TOP MODEL.
SHE HAS THE PERSONALITY.
SHE'S AN EXAGGERATION.
SHE'S LIKE A WALKING
EXCLAMATION MARK,
AND IT'S NOT PRETTY.
MICHELLE.
MICHELLE--IN PERSON,
SHE'S JUST NOT THERE.
SHE'S WEAK.
SHE'S NERVOUS.
THERE IS A SILVER LINING
TO MICHELLE.
SHE CAN PULL OUT
A BEAUTIFUL PICTURE.
THAT'S THE SILVER LINING?
YES, THIS IS NOT
A BAD PICTURE.
THIS IS A GOOD PICTURE.
KAHLEN.
SHE REALLY GOT THIS DEER,
AND I KNOW THIS ANIMAL WELL.
HOW WELL DO YOU KNOW IT?
IT'S MY NATIONAL ANIMAL.
CHRISTINA.
SHE'S REALLY BROUGHT
HER BIRDLIKE FEATURES
TO A HEAD HERE.
THIS IS
THE PERFECT OSTRICH.
IN PERSON, CHRISTINA,
YOU WERE A LITTLE BIT
OF THAT ICE QUEEN AGAIN.
KEENYAH.
I THINK KEENYAH HAS HAD IT
TOO GOOD FOR TOO LONG.
KEENYAH'S BEING EXTREMELY
PLEASED WITH HERSELF.
SHE'S SLIPPING WEEK BY WEEK
FOR ME.
SHE'S GETTING
A LITTLE TOO ELEPHANT FOR ME.
- SHE'S OUT.
- TAKES ONE TO KNOW ONE.
THANK YOU. PROUD OF IT.
SIX BEAUTIFUL LADIES
STAND BEFORE ME,
BUT UNFORTUNATELY ONE OF YOU
HAS TO GO HOME TONIGHT.
THE FIRST NAME
THAT I'M GOING TO CALL...
KAHLEN.
WHO IS THIS GIRL STANDING
IN FRONT OF ME THIS WEEK?
I DON'T RECOGNIZE HER.
YOU MAY HAVE BEEN
A SPRINGBOK THIS WEEK,
BUT YOU'RE THE LION.
CONGRATULATIONS.
YOU'RE STILL IN THE RUNNING
TOWARDS BECOMING
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL.
THANK YOU.
THE NEXT NAME
THAT I'M GOING TO CALL...
CHRISTINA.
CHRISTINA, YOU LEARNED TODAY
THAT EVERY MODEL,
AS YOU KNOW, HAS FLAWS,
AND EVERYBODY HAS TRICKS.
YOU LEARNED
A NEW TRICK TODAY.
CONGRATULATIONS.
THANK YOU.
NAIMA.
I'M GONNA BE
REALLY HONEST WITH YOU.
TODAY I WAS DRIVING UP
TO THIS JUDGING,
AND I WENT THROUGH
ALL THE GIRLS,
AND FOR SOME REASON,
I FORGOT ABOUT NAIMA
'CAUSE NAIMA'S PERSONALITY
DOESN'T POP.
IT DOESN'T MAKE ME
REMEMBER YOU
WHEN I GO HOME AT NIGHT
AND GO TO SLEEP
AND THINK ABOUT THE GIRLS.
I KNOW THERE'S SOMETHING IN YOU
THAT IS SO BEAUTIFUL,
AND I FEEL LIKE
YOU'RE STIFLING IT.
THANK YOU.
BRITTANY.
BRITTANY, YOU HAVE
THIS BEAUTIFUL,
EFFERVESCENT PERSONALITY,
BUT FROM WEEK TO WEEK,
YOUR TESTS--
YOU'RE JUST FALLING APART.
YOU HAVE TO USE
YOUR STRENGTH
TO GET TO THE HEAD
OF THIS PACK.
CONGRATULATIONS.
WILL KEENYAH AND MICHELLE
PLEASE STEP FORWARD?
I ONLY HAVE ONE PHOTO
IN MY HANDS,
AND THIS PHOTO REPRESENTS
THE GIRL THAT WILL STILL BE
IN THE RUNNING
TOWARDS BECOMING
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL.
I WILL ONLY CALL ONE NAME.
THE GIRL THAT I DO NOT CALL
MUST IMMEDIATELY PACK HER BAGS
AND RETURN HOME.
TWO OF YOU HAVE
VERY DIFFERENT STRENGTHS.
MICHELLE, YOU HAVE A FACE
THAT IS RARE,
BUT YOU FALL APART
UNDER PRESSURE,
AND BEING A TOP MODEL
MEANS BEING UNDER PRESSURE
CONSTANTLY,
BEING SCRUTINIZED,
BROKEN DOWN AND PICKED APART.
WE'RE NOT SURE IF YOU'RE
STRONG ENOUGH FOR THAT.
KEENYAH,
WHEN WE LOOK AT YOU,
WE DON'T SEE A MODEL,
AND AS MUCH AS I HATE
AND PREACH ABOUT MODELS
NOT HAVING TO BE
STICK-SKINNY,
WE HAVE TO FACE IT THAT
WE ARE IN THE FASHION INDUSTRY.
IF YOU DON'T FIT THE CLOTHES,
YOU DON'T WORK.
BOTH OF YOU GUYS' WEAKNESS--
I DON'T THINK THERE'S TIME
FOR EITHER OF YOU
TO OVERCOME THEM.
BUT WE'VE BEEN IN
THIS INDUSTRY FOR A LONG TIME,
AND THESE JUDGES HAVE
SEEN MIRACLES HAPPEN.
KEENYAH.
- CONGRATULATIONS.
- THANK YOU.
YOU'RE GONNA WORK
ON YOURSELF?
GET IT TOGETHER?
BUT HEALTHY.
YOU'RE STILL IN THE RUNNING
TOWARDS BECOMING
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU, MICHELLE.
(sobbing)
THANK YOU, GUYS, SO MUCH.
I APPRECIATE IT.
THANK YOU.
ROCK 'EM HARD.
YOUR TIME WILL COME,
SWEETIE.
I WANTED THIS MORE
THAN ANYTHING IN THE WORLD.
I CAN'T EVEN,
LIKE, EXPLAIN
HOW MUCH I WANTED TO
BE UP THERE, BE NUMBER ONE,
BE THE BEST.
WHEN I CAME IN HERE,
I WAS EVEN MORE SHY AND TIMID,
AND THE ADVICE I HAVE GOTTEN
AND THE CRITICISM
I HAVE GOTTEN
HAS HELPED ME CHANGE,
DEFINITELY.
I'VE JUST BECOME
MORE CONFIDENT,
AND I ACTUALLY--
I FEEL BEAUTIFUL.
I DON'T THINK I'VE EVER
TRULY FELT THAT BEFORE.
STAY TUNED FOR SCENES
FROM OUR NEXT EPISODE.
COMING UP ON
"AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL"--
THE GIRLS RACE TO IMPRESS
SOUTH AFRICA'S FASHION ELITE,
WHICH BRINGS OUT
KEENYAH'S COMPETITIVE SIDE.
CHEATER!
BUT ALL THEIR CLAWS
COME OUT
WHEN THE GIRLS
HAVE TO CRITIQUE
EACH OTHER'S PHOTOS
AT JUDGING.
I DO THINK
IT MAKES HER LOOK THICKER.
IT LOOKS LIKE SHE'S SMELLING
SOMETHING ROTTEN.
I SEE MAYBE DIRTY
IN HER UNDERWEAR.